dream kardashian and saint west singing  happy birthday to Kylie Jenner is the  cutest thing you'll see all day the life  of Kylie star turned 20 years old on  Thursday and celebrated with her nearest  and dearest including the youngest  members of the kardashian-jenner family  Rob's nine month-old daughter dream and  Kim's 20 month old son Saint were  front-row Center as the family circled  around the birthday girl and her cake in  addition to receiving some sweet  birthday messages from her siblings on  social media and tons of flowers from  friends Kylie was showered with love at  a surprise party on Wednesday night  [Music]  [Applause]  yes enjoyed a chocolate fountain  balloons that spelled out Kylie a cake  featuring a silly image of the 20 year  old and an ice sculpture of Kylie's body